es momento de hablar de economía está
conmigo en el estudio jorge hurtado de
nicaragua para el mundo como siempre y
este viernes jorge los venezolanos van a
vivir la tercera reconversión de la
moneda venezolana así es venezuela va a
quitar seis ceros a su moneda y el
bolívar soberano pasará a llamarse el
bolívar digital este viernes entre en
vigencia otra reconversión monetaria que
quitará cero por tercera ocasión desde
2008 su moneda esta vez el gobierno
venezolano eliminará seis ceros según el
banco central de venezuela el nuevo
nombre se debe al desarrollo de la
economía digital en venezuela las
reconversiones son usuales en países con
situación inflacionaria en los últimos
12 meses la inflación del país en
latinoamérica no avanzó mil 743 por
ciento el gobierno de nicolás maduro
restringió el gasto público y limitó el
crédito pero los precios siguen
aumentando escuchemos qué opinan los
venezolanos de este cambio
o sea me dólares hasta a mí me está
pagando 7 millones de bolívares
mensuales y qué hago yo sí hago me
cuesta 55 dólares 5 por 4 20 son 20
millones y ohl 21 millones que me cuesta
esto por ejemplo lo ha ganado lo
los dólares 4 millones lo pagamos el
precio la página pasada cuesta dos
millones
estoy tratando de entender eso de
economía digital en venezuela jorge
hablemos ahora del precio de las
viviendas en eeuu que lo que está
pasando allí bueno el índice de precios
de viviendas en 20 ciudades de estados
unidos se disparó un 19.1 por ciento en
junio en comparación al año anterior y
representó el mayor aumento en los
últimos 30 años los especialistas
adjudican santiago este aumento a la
escasez de propiedades asequibles
mientras la demanda ha crecido ciudades
como nueva york boston dallas y denver
se encuentran entre las ciudades que
registraron aumentos récords en los
últimos años la pandemia hizo que muchos
estadounidenses trabajaran desde casa
esto los motivó a buscar viviendas en
áreas suburbanas que brinden más espacio
y los lejos completamente de las grandes
ciudades sin embargo los precios altos
se están enfriando sé por las ventas es
otro estudio reveló que la venta de
viviendas usadas aumentó apenas 1.5 por
ciento en julio con respecto al año
anterior hablemos ahora de brasil porque
hay datos hay cifras sobre el empleo
mensual allí en la economía más grande
de suramérica así es esa economía generó
372 mil 265 nuevos empleos formales en
agosto ese es un mejor resultado del año
desde febrero cuando fueron abiertas
397.000 plazas respecto al acumulado
2021 brasil generó un total de 2.2
millones de empleos formales en los
primeros 8 meses de este año frente a
las 849 mil plazas de trabajos formales
que se perdieron entre enero y agosto
del 2020 cuando fueron afectados por la
crisis económica provocada por la
pandemia el ministerio del trabajo y
seguridad social destacó que el empleo
formal aumentó en los cinco grandes
sectores productivos de ese país
destacando el sector servicios donde
fueron creados ciento mil nuevos puestos
laborales pese al buen desempeño del
empleo santiago formal en los últimos
meses la pandemia se disparó el
desempleo al 14,1 por ciento en brasil
donde se calcula que hay más de 30
millones de personas trabajando en la
informalidad la informalidad la realidad
de américa latina' hablemos ahora de la
organización de naciones unidas que
abogó por los países que son
considerados pobres así es el secretario
general de esa organización antonio
guterres solicitó 1.2 billones de
dólares al año para proteger a países
pobres guterres intervino para pedir
solidaridad internacional según él hacen
falta medidas de estímulo fiscal
valoradas y 982 mil millones de dólares
para responder a los problemas
inmediatos en el mercado laboral el
principal argumento de güter es que los
países de ingresos medios y bajos apenas
están interviniendo entre dos y seis por
ciento de su producto interno bruto en
la recuperación económica tras la
pandemia esto debido a la deuda que
tienen y el poco espacio fiscal
disponible en contraste según guterres
con las economías más grandes que
invierte en casi el 28 por ciento de su
producto interno bruto para el cierre de
los indicadores bueno wall street cerró
mixto con baja en el sector tecnológico
por los movimientos en el mercado de
deuda en europa la bolsa de recuperaron
las pérdidas de ayer con la ayuda del
alza en nueva york' y las bolsas de
américa latina también mostraron una
leve mejoría por el arrastre que
significó las pérdidas en europa y eeuu
y la cifra del día para el cierre 13.1
por ciento aumentó el precio promedio de
renta en un apartamento en eeuu desde la
pandemia interesante cifra muchas
gracias jorge por esta actualización del
mundo económico es todo por el momento
aquí en france 24 buenas noches
[Música]